Many of the applications and operating
systems that we currently use have
vulnerabilities. One of the problems
though is that we've not found those
vulnerabilities yet. The vulnerabilities
are somewhere within the inner workings
of those applications and operating
systems, but we just haven't found where
they are quite yet. Fortunately, there
are very smart people that are
researching and trying to find these
vulnerabilities before the attackers do.
Most of the time, these good guys will
work directly with the publishers and
developers of the applications and the
operating systems to close those
particular vulnerabilities before
they're found by someone else. Very
often, attackers will find
vulnerabilities in these operating
systems, but won't tell anyone the
vulnerability exists. That's because
they would like to take advantage of
these vulnerabilities and exploit them
before anyone else knows that the
problem is even there. A brand new
vulnerability that has only recently
been identified and perhaps may not have
a sufficient way to mitigate is referred
to as a zeroday vulnerability. Attackers
love to take advantage of these
vulnerabilities because there might not
be a patch available yet for the
operating system or the application and
before a patch has been released, they
can now create exploits and try to take
advantage of that vulnerability. These
vulnerabilities happen a lot more than
you might think. And one way that you
could track them is through a CVE. This
is the common vulnerabilities and
exposures database and you can find this
at cve.mmeriter.org.
Very often these zeroday vulnerabilities
may only affect a relatively small
number of operating systems or
applications. But there was one type of
zeroday vulnerability that affected
millions of devices that were publicly
available over the internet. This was
the log 4j remote code execution
vulnerability and it was discovered on
December the 9th of 2021. Log 4j is a
service provided from Apache that runs
as a javabased logging utility and it is
installed on millions of servers around
the world. What's interesting about this
vulnerability is not just its size but
how long it had been sitting dormant.
The code that allowed this vulnerability
to exist was introduced on September the
14th of 2013, but we did not discover it
until 2021. Between December the 9th and
December the 14th, we had a zeroday
vulnerability. Fortunately, a patch was
released 5 days later, and there was a
huge amount of effort that went underway
to apply that patch to the millions of
devices that were affected. It turns out
that was not the only vulnerability
associated with this software. Since so
many people were now affected by this
software, you had a lot more researchers
looking at the code of log 4j. And we
found two additional issues that were
fixed on December 17th. This is a very
good example of how vulnerabilities can
sit dormant inside of software until
someone comes across a vulnerability
that might affect millions of devices.